Speaker 1: And finally today, that footage that
Tucker Carlson got his hands on, 44000 hours of
footage from January 6th. Security cameras all
over Congress given to him by Kevin McCarthy.
A coalition of news organizations are now suing
the federal government to get their hands on
that very same footage that has been handed over
to Tucker Carlson. Those organizations include
advanced publications, the Associated Press,
CNN, CBS, the E.W. Scripps Company, Gannett,
the New York Times, Politico, and ProPublica. And
basically what they've done is they've sued the
federal government. Well, not necessarily sued
the federal government. That may be the wrong
word. They filed a motion in federal court saying
that we have jumped through all the hoops. We
have filled out all the paperwork, the Freedom
of Information Act requests, asking the FBI,
the DOJ to turn over this same footage, which is
technically already publicly available via Tucker
Carlson. So it's not like it's hidden. It's not
like it's top secret or classified. We want this
information. So the news organizations are asking
the court to compel the government to turn it over
to them. I hope this lawsuit works. I think it
needs to work for the good of the country because
Tucker Carlson got that footage and did exactly
what everybody predicted he was going to do. He
showed weird camera angles that just showed people
walking down a hallway. And then he was like, See,
they're not violent. It's just like tourists
on a trip. They're learning it's a field trip.
And of course, he admitted all of the part where
they're breaking windows, climbing up walls,
smashing bases, stealing stuff, jumping over
chairs with a bundle of zip ties on their
belt. Yeah, all the really important things
Tucker Carlson said. Yeah, we don't need to
talk about that. He's whitewashing the events
of that day to make Republicans look better.
These news organizations want that same footage
so that they can show what really happened.
You can't just show a piece of the puzzle and
say, Oh, yes, clearly that is a basket of puppies.
You have to put the whole puzzle together,
every single piece of it. And another thing
that I think Tucker Carlson didn't take into
consideration is that those people that he's shown
just walking around that building, being peaceful.
They're very presence in that building is what's
a crime, because even if they were just walking
around, they were still trespassing on federal
property and interrupting an official government
proceeding. So those videos Tucker showed could
actually lead to more prosecutions and arrests in
the future. Listen, that's all the time we have
for today. I've got an exceptionally fun bonus
show coming up. Thank you, David. Thank you,
team, for letting me fill in for these last
two days. I am Farron Cousins. You can find
me on YouTube at YouTube dot com slash the Ring of
Fire youtube.com slash fair and balanced Twitter,
Facebook, Instagram, TikTok at Fair and Balanced.
Thank you so much. Stay tuned for the bonus show.